LELAND: WELCOME BACK.
LAST WEEK VETERANS UNITED ASKED
FOR YOUR MOTHER’S DAY MESSAGES
TO SOME OF THE MOMS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC, AND NOW WE WANT TO
SHARE SOME OF THOSE LETTERS WITH
YOU.
WE BRING IN CHIEF MASTER
SERGEANT FROM THE D.C. AIR
NATIONAL GUARD.
NICE TO SEE YOU, MA’AM.
YOU THINK ABOUT MOMS WHO ARE
CELEBRATING TODAY, AS WELL THEY
SHOULD BE, AND THEN WE THINK
ABOUT ALL THE MOMS WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES WHETHER IT’S
DEPLOYED WITH THE MILITARY OR ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC WHO CAN’T
BE CELEBRATED REALLY IN THE WAY
THAT WE’D LIKE TO, WITH FLOWERS
AND BREAKFAST, ETC.
WHAT OPTIONS ARE THERE FOR THEM?
>> WE HAVE SEVERAL MEMBERS AND,
JUST LIKE YOU SAID, THEY’RE
ACTUALLY TODAY SERVING IN
VARIOUS LOCATIONS IN D.C.,
HELPING OUT WITH THE CITIZENS OF
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, THEY CAN’T
BE HOPE HOME WITH THEIR
CHILDREN -- HOME WITH THEIR
CHILDRENNED TODAY.
SO I’VE SENT SEVERAL TEXT
MESSAGES AND I’M SURE SEVERAL
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE SENT MESSAGES
JUST TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND --
LELAND: WHAT ARE THEY DOING
SPECIFICICALLY?
>> WE HAVE AIRMEN AND SOLDIERS
OUT THERE THE AT CERTAIN
SUPERMARKETS IN SOUTHEAST D.C.,
WE ALSO HAVE MEMBERS WHO ARE
DOING SCREAMING AT VARIOUS
HOSPITALS -- SCREENING AT
VARIOUS HOSPITALS FOR COVID-19
TESTING.
WE ALSO HAVE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PREPARING OUR ALTERNATE CARE
FACILITY THAT’LL BE OPENING UP
SOON, SO THEY’LL OUT THERE
WORKING.
LELAND: WOW.
SO LAST WEEK WE ASKED FOR SOME
MESSAGES, AND I THINK THERE HAVE
BEEN A HOT THAT HAVE COME IN,
CORRECT FINISH A LOT THAT HAVE
COME IN, CORRECT?
>> YES.
LELAND: OH, AWESOME.
CAN YOU SHARE SOME OF THEM?
>> SURE.
DEAR HERO, I’M A MILITARY SPOUSE
FOR 20 YEARS AND THE MOTHER TO
MILITARY BRATS WHO WENT THROUGH
THREE DEPLOYMENTS.
I KNOW WHY YOU SERVE.
I KNOW MY LIFE IS BETTER FOR IT.
THANK YOU, LAURA.
HAPPY MOTHER’S DAY.
DEAR HERO, WORDS IS CANNOT
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
I CAN IMAGINE HOW HARD IT IS TO
BE AWAY FROM LOVED ONES DURING
THIS TIME.
I HOPE YOU KNOW YOU ARE
APPRECIATED.
YOUR COURAGE INSPIRES ME AND SO
MANY TO OTHERS.
I’M KEEPING YOU IN MY PRAYERS
AND SENDING LOVE WITH THIS NOTE
OF GRATITUDE.
WITH LOVE AND THANKS --
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE, YOU
ROCK.
SIDNEY.
THE CALVIN FAMILY.
LELAND: ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC.
I THINK WE SAW THERE A COUPLE OF
PICTURES WITH YOU WITH YOUR SON,
CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
LELAND: AWESOME.
WHAT ARE Y’ALL DOING FOR
MOTHER’S DAY?
>> RIGHT NOW WE’RE JUST
RELAXING.
MY HUSBAND WENT OUT AND PICKED
UP SOME DINNER, AND ACTUALLY MY
SON IS ASLEEP, WHICH IS GREAT --
[LAUGHTER]
LELAND: THE BEST MOTHER’S DAY
PRESENT IS A LITTLE BIT OF PEACE
AND QUIET.
WELL, WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING
US, THANK YOU.
HAPPY MOTHER’S DAY TO YOU AND,
OBVIOUSLY, TO THOSE MOMS OUT
THERE ON THE FRONT LINES.
WE’RE GLAD WE GOT A CHANCE TO